when you look at the moon in the night
sky it might seem reasonably close but
it's actually incredibly far away
right over here is a scaled picture of
the distance between the earth and the
moon
earth has a diameter
of approximately eight thousand
miles
while the moon has a diameter of
approximately
2200 miles so a little bit more than
one-fourth diameter of earth now the
distance between the two
is 239
000 miles
which you can imagine is incredibly far
now one thing that is very interesting
this is why the moon looks like it's the
same size as the sun in the sky even
though it is 1 400th of the diameter
is the ratio between the distance to the
moon and the diameter of the moon is
roughly the same as the ratio of the
distance of the sun to the diameter of
the sun so for the moon that ratio the
distance to the moon 239
000 will do everything in miles
over the radius of the moon 2200 it's
approximately the same as the ratio
between the distance from earth to the
sun which would be 93 million
miles
over
000 miles in diameter so this number is
roughly 400 times larger than that
number and this number is roughly 400
times larger than that number but what's
neat is and this depends on where earth
is in its orbit but this is
approximately equal to
108.
this gives me goosebumps whenever i
think about it because
it didn't have to be this way that the
moon and the sun even though they have
these vastly different diameters that
they look roughly the same size in the
sky because the ratio of the distances
is comparable to the ratio of their
diameters and this is why the number 108
is actually an auspicious number in some
cultures especially in hinduism now when
you're discussing the moon and
especially the moon as viewed from earth
one of the obvious questions is why does
the moon go through phases why do we see
different portions of the moon lit up
from day to day
this right over here is a diagram from
nasa's website and what you see here
clearly this is not at scale this
picture over here this inner picture the
size of the moon and the earth is
roughly at scale but clearly the
distances between them are not you don't
see that 239 thousand miles between them
in this inner circle what you see is
that the moon and the earth is always
lit up from the right so it's assuming
that the sun is 93 million miles in that
direction and it is lighting up both the
earth and the moon from the right
now as the moon rotates
around the earth in its 28-day cycle and
if you're wondering gee a 28-day cycle
seems awfully close to a month that is
not a coincidence the notion of a month
comes from the cycles of the moon in
fact even the word month
and the word moon
have the exact same root in old english
and in proto-germanic they are
essentially the same word
but what you see is the moon goes in
this 28-day cycle when the moon is
roughly between the earth and the sun
the lit up half of the moon is away from
what we can see here on earth and so we
see the non-lit up side which would be a
new moon now as the moon goes this is
viewing from above the earth this would
be the north pole right over here as it
goes counterclockwise as viewed from
above the earth we start to be able to
see a little bit of that half of the
moon that gets lit up so when the moon
is in this position we see us from earth
from this vantage point we're able to
see a little bit of the lit up side when
the moon is over here we're able to see
half the lit up side and half the
non-lit up side and that's called a
first quarter moon and that keeps on
going when we're halfway through our
cycle here at a full moon the earth is
between the moon and the sun and so from
our vantage point we are able to see the
entire lit up side and that's why it is
a full moon and then we keep going all
the way until we get back to a new moon
now one question that might be bothering
you it bothered me for many years is as
soon as i understood this the cycle of
the moon how the moon has this 28 day
cycle as earth rotates around the sun
i always wondered well in a new moon it
looks like the moon is between the earth
and the sun
why doesn't it block out the sun every
time we have a new moon why don't we
have a solar eclipse
every 28 days similarly for the full
moons when we're in this position it
looks like the earth is between the moon
and the sun why does an earth's shadow
block out the sun so that we have a
lunar eclipse instead of a full moon and
we would have one of those every 28 days
why don't we see that
think about it yourself what's a
plausible explanation in the next video
we'll actually talk about why
eclipses both solar eclipses when the
moon blocks out the sun and lunar
eclipses when the earth's shadow falls
on the moon why they're not happening
every 28 days